devenu un rituel pour les blésois depuis
2013 les contres marches de l'escalier
denis papin sont régulièrement décoré
pour créer des visuels plus originaux
les uns que les autres
après mona lisa mickey ou lucky luke cet
été les passants pourront se reposer au
milieu des ouvrages d'une bibliothèque
géante et les titres qui s'y trouvent
n'ont pas été choisies au hasard
les explications de rémy quart temps en
haut de ses 120 marches la statue de
denis papin veille sur la cité de blois
et depuis peu sur une drôle de
bibliothèque pour habiller cet escalier
monumental la ville de blois a décidé de
mettre le livre à l'honneur harry potter
sherlock holmes 1984 se trompe l'oeil
géant suscite la curiosité des blésois
et des touristes qui gravissent les
marches du mam ou simple à lire tous les
livres et voir quelles j'ai lu et
qu'elle j'ai pas lu et surtout très
intéressant la prospective et les
jusqu'à les vues des loin sur l'escalier
90 ouvrages sélectionnés par les
habitants grâce un sondage lancé par la
ville la réalisation de l'oeuvre a été
confiée à l'artiste philippe merlevede
qui ne prend pas directement les marches
mais travaille dans son atelier à une
échelle réduite intervient pour réaliser
l'image en fait donc la peinture que je
réalise au 10e c'est à dire dix fois
plus petit que ce que vous voyez là mais
quand même un quasiment à 1070 de haut
parce qu'il ya 17 mètres de l'escalier
après confection l'oeuvre est imprimé
sur des bandes adhésives par une
entreprise de signalétique pour être
parfaite la pause nécessite beaucoup de
temps de minutie et d'efforts nous avons
pratiquement 1200 mètres d'adhésifs à
poser et nous avons aussi bon un souci
de repérage pour que ce soit parfait
donc au départ beaucoup de repérage à
l'atelier après impression et après
c'est un peu de souffrance on va dire au
niveau de nos articulations et au niveau
du temps à passer sous des fois les
conditions difficiles cette célébration
estivale du livre ne se limitera pas aux
escaliers denis papin pour qu'à blois
l'art se plante partout dans la cité à
la manière d'un avion en papier